o os índios em outubro altura em que for
de sua vida quando eu tinha 14 anos de
idade e gênero da minha mãe e disse mãe
eu quero procurar um trabalho e ajudar
nas despesas da casa
a iniciativa
a expectativa é grande
ela falou que a filha que cavalgar novos
ares tinha grande isso não pra ele olha
a realidade hoje
lobato pensando eu ouvi o que quer mudar
o estilo sobre o nome da minha família
para mudar essa realidade que eu
encontro acho que é um sonho grande
demais e isso não é caminho eu me deitei
foi de barba
eu trabalhei do ano eo brasil ea meta
era ajudar meus pais
nessa época eu era no interior
eu e meu pai sempre foi pedida de casa e
mais três irmãs foi o de muito amor mas
também compartilhar com vocês hoje não é
às vezes a gente tem pouco recurso e
vamos mais uma força de vontade diante
das coisas acontecer então espero ser um
investidor para colocar a idéia em
prática o fez chegar o momento que você
está pensando na sua vida entre você tem
aonde você estiver dependente essa coisa
social
junte mais uma fonte nova se derrotar
girão explica que as coisas não vão
acontecer de alguma forma você vai ter
um resultado
les hinton é melhor do que perfeito
assim então eu tive essa fase dura da
infância do concelho os nossos pais
muitas vezes a gente acredita aqui a
esse conselho é muito chato isso não é
pra mim uma vítima a fazer toda a
diferença na nossa vida
e o terceiro é valorizar e comemorar as
pequenas vitórias a gente deixou de
comemorar quando encontrou o pote de
ouro veio com aquela vitória de hoje
bom fim de ano de idade eu encontrava a
fazer lição de vida meu propósito seguir
a universidade enfrenta
eu comecei a minha mãe
super feliz por causa disso mas eu não
estava feliz
eu realmente estava trabalhando com a
pagar as contas no final do mês
o confiança eu pensei se eu colocar
velocidade
as coisas vão melhorar para mim com
certeza continuou em mãos teria lhe as
portas mais facilmente e melhorar a
qualidade da minha família gostou e
desde criança estava totalmente enganado
não sei se meus mesmo
eu fiquei muito decepcionado puxa é a
universidade pode proporcionar
seria muito mais o derrubando a minha
comunicação e tira um pouco a melhorar
na internet procurar um canal que
pudesse tirar minhas dúvidas dá um lote
na vida sabe lá e jesus valor
o facebook eu vi coxa e ficará fora rio
ele tem uma visão de mundo e de que
pensar e agir fora da china não é algo
que queria trabalhar simplesmente para
pagar a conta no final dei é o que a
maioria da sociedade faz aquilo que foi
proposto de vida uma missão pacau uma
mexida se dedicar e fazer por ela é um
lado certo mas que poucas pessoas sabem
disso e se divertindo à multidão
eu gosto é por aí que este bando de
sonhadores de novo que eu fiz foi um
grande e eu vou ficar fechado e vai
acompanhar todos os dias direção de
valor
os vídeos do youtube o post no facebook
e foi a melhoria virtual que eu recebi
daquele legal jamais filho conhecido
pessoalmente eu tinha nenhuma prioridade
à infância tinha em 2011 você no
facebook os meus amigos virtuais que
deve gerar seu empresa
ele gera uma caixa de presente na
verdade presente não falei o que é bom
sobretudo quando eu recebi 44 endereços
de pessoas golpe e que iriam receber o
presente e eu pensei hoje que tanta
gente como é que eu gostava tanto
dinheiro que a naná ia correr para
diversos estados do brasil
essa é a minha promessa né eu tenho
feito
preferencialmente show está no livro de
receitas de cuidados até hoje eu tenho
uma caixa cheia de rios de receita e
aquela época eu estava cada ano novo que
houve ocorrência em vilamoura demorada e
eu falava poxa ela ganhasse uma um carro
presente físico mesmo material é
detalhista da felicidade porque
realmente vibrava com as caixinhas com
os livros que eu recebia as empresas de
alimentos e eu pensei eu gostaria de
receber uma cartilha casa criticou
mourinho deu sabe eu acho que foi uma
jogada inteira escreveu um artigo
diferente porque eu tinha utilidade
diferente de hoje e não tem valor
especial eo a curitiba
significativas a mim e eu vou aí muita
gente a escorrer e lá você tem que
reagir o poder
eu não disse que eu sou maluco
e foi o que ele tivesse corrido lá
conversando com um atendente
eu comecei até o dia caxias para
serventias cair na base de baixo eo
limite todo o sabor da cartinha cultura
para empenhado e aí pegou o carro ao
filho
eu disse puxa a uma cirurgia ter nada
com meu carro né
eu ia colocar dia feliz da vida com os
seus em cada uma delas
achei o texto e lá sai na rua vibra foi
44 cardíaca vários estados do brasil
marcelo eu falei não é o resultado disso
foi o marinheiro reforço já foi plantado
cachinhos de ouro de dentro daquilo que
foi o estreito e de século 20 como algo
diferenciado e além disso esse pedido de
namoro
apaixonado pela minha atitude de
chocolate presentinho dessa caixinha
caiu na casa do fundador do projeto que
hoje vou assim o que o governo nacional
e citados acima da média no brasil
eu estava trabalhando como operadora de
caixa de supermercado e ele falou do
projeto da realidade da cadeia e josivan
hoje vir também segunda geração de ouro
como o jovem diferencial de que há um
profundo
inconformada a partir deste momento com
danielle e começou a emitir em santa
catarina e em são paulo na cidade
cosmopolita
um bom projeto de difícil de implementar
porque é tudo virtual o conheci e até
dois anos atrás mas com uma pegada muito
gostoso qualidade hd atividade que
deixou cheio de orgulho a cidade em
cidade melhor com o mercado de trabalho
origem pra gente aqui é mais o
envolvimento de sua vida
a atitude iniciativa dessa mentalidade
vamos aprender e compartilhar histórias
de empreendedores da cidade de doha ele
prevê que cada pessoa que fazia vibrar
de felicidade ea conquista da cidade há
um ano e meio
puxa vida com geraldo filho a água
enquanto uma hora uma hora e meia do seu
tempo a compartilhar com nove jogos
parelhos a sua história de vida seus
veículos a cas suas dicas pra gente
grita é um sucesso sabe não levantando
já estão vindo do 44º ter pago o senhor
ela e marido da lei foi o executivo
atacou israel e do castelo passou pelo
nosso bate-papo do mê
e apesar da idade foi a um trilho
partilhou com a gente uma história de
vida que jesus deixou tudo é de boca
aberta
apesar da idéia de idade para entender e
compartilhar sua história com a gente
agora é e de uma das meninas que
trabalham comigo ela é já estava errado
é diretora de acompanhamento e nem
fração de mercado acima da média é
colocar
sons é criar nas ruas de ações até
assustam e levar alguma novamente e só o
seu sonho colocação em realidade
é o que a gente faz em que o que já
tenho a mim então sejam todos bem vindos
com isso nosso projeto embora todos pan
a pergunta que você está chegando jorge
bom ele é não ter lei
eu poderia fazer aqui em 28 afi a equipe
dizendo que esse projeto transforma as
pessoas eu faria o percurso partida
jamais imaginaria que um dia estaria
aqui no palco do caged eo avaí
transformou minha vida transformada em
sinal de ser um ser humano melhor
eis aqui depoimento do andrade mineiro
um superfã do lcd é um privilégio ter
acesso a esse conteúdo de qualidade que
a equipe do a ele produto que
compartilha o nosso amigo de alegria ele
fala dos melhores projetos de qualidade
a companhia pode todos os passos que
sempre geram mensais eu adoro
alguém já os nossos resultados com a
equipe
a agitação livro vida se inspira onde
conta a gente nova história de jovens
sonhadores em pdf gráfica toda nossa
comunidade acadêmica do brasil realiza
um congresso uma idéia acima da média
onde a gente faz uma melhoria virtual
online selecionou as melhores idéias do
brasil e conectando os comentadores
muito top e ainda o l1 hickman no
passado também gratuitamente para nossos
jogos
bom tem uma história do jec no final
conhece de fato do pé o filme regiões
selecionadas pela previsão de geração de
valor fóruns brasil está com esse apelo
de 2014 eu fui a primeira menina
selecionada para este caso isso com ele
talvez 2008 john essa história todo
mundo cansado nem aí estão algumas fotos
para vocês é encontrar a vocês hoje a
escola que ninguém estava por trás disso
jamais imaginaria que seria uma vez vão
selecionar o homem interior onde
trabalha o flamengo sempre morou em
portugal e que ele havia 2 262 que ele
escolher o potencial de liderança para
estar com ele caso isso pra mim é um
sonho e vou seguir aquele com o vidro
como mestre desde 2001 e eu tentei algo
novo está buscando realizar esse som
eu pensei pô se eu fosse uma das
selecionadas é preciso ter visto para
fazer isso mas eu não tenho então eu
tenho andado velhos trabalham diz que
tem 32 horas até a rodoviária do tietê
em são paulo na casa de um ano e os
beijos meus monstros interiores que é a
cidade que na finalidade roubo do mais
mas sim pela primeira vez na cidade isso
o jogador a caminho de uma cidade
pequenininha fantástico quando o usuário
com vício na mão eu irei ver a atitude
selecionar jovens um outro caso de o
shopping conhecimentos dos alunos da
silva e também se divertir na disney em
entre os partidos
bom vocês compartilhar com vocês aqui é
só ele e fechados e que em conjunto com
a realidade das pessoas que construíram
a história de vocês
rg caneta pega o papel a sua o controle
subiu no palco fala bonito
obrigado